وهذه الصور هذه الصور تاتينا مباشره منها
تاعي وعلى الهواء مباشره لاداره الكوارث
التركيه التي قالت في اخر خبر لها بان
زلزال كان بقوه 64
وانه ضرب ولايه هاتاي الجنوبي تركيا قيل
بان هذه الهزه وكانت لها اصداء شعر بها
سكان في بعض المناطق في لبنان وحتى في غزه
ما زلنا هذه الصور لنتابعها من هاتاي وقد
وصلتنا قبل قليل حيث مناطقي
وعدد من الذين تضرروا بفعل الزلزال
ونلاحظ هنا فرق الاسعاف وقف فرق الطوارئ
قد
هرعت الى المنطقه
هناك صراخ كما نسمع يبدو ان هناك
ضحايا او ان هناك اضرار كثيره لحقت بهذه
المباني
ولا نعرف بالضبط حتى الان الرقم الحقيقي
البعض قال سته فاصله ثلاثه في العشر على
مقياس نختر مصدر اخر قال حوالي سته فاصله
خمسه بالعشره واخرا اخيرا اداره الكوارث
التركيه تتحدث عن سته فاصله اربعه من عشره
وان هذه المنطقه التي ضربت هي فيها
الداعيه التي نشاهد هذه الصور قد وردتنا
قبل قليل من اتاي في جنوبي تركيا بعض
المصادر تقول بان هذا زلزال ضرب ايضا
مناطق في سوريا
الارتدادات هذه الهزه التي قيل بان تستمرت
لمده عشرين ثانيه